[Musique]
mais
non
plus dwyer vous venez d'une famille
d'artistes votre mère c'est jane birkin
comédiennes chanteuses conjointe de
serge gainsbourg votre père réalisateur
français jean chris baio commencent à se
pencher des briques ndoye on a ce qu'on
écoute de la musique ensemble lorsqu'on
en arrive avec un disque ou un conseil
de famille lorsque chaque membre créer
une oeuvre artistique
non pas du tout il ya une grande pudeur
de la part de tout le monde donc non ma
mère est assez rigolote là tu ma mère
effectivement est très fan et une fois
que l'album est fini je lui envoie parce
que ça me ça me touche ça me fait
plaisir et puis j'ai envie d'avoir son
avis un avis qui compte mais ils
interviennent quand c'est fini
c'est impensable qu'ils viennent me voir
en studio que je les laisserai pas
rentrer et d'amran faire là dessus j'ai
été élevé par des créateurs qui n'ont
jamais mon père et j'apprends par la
presse
les films qui fait charlotte j'apprends
par la presse les choses qu'elle fait le
mamère pareil on est on est on est pas
au courant quand on se voit on parle de
on parle de choses de la vie de l'amour
de la bouffe des enfants de mais parce
que c'est sacré se mettre au travail et
et la famille c'est un pouvoir terrible
d'une manière ça peu n'importe quelle
famille si d'un coup vous faites quelque
chose et que je sais plus utiliser ça où
c'était assez drôle la mère d'un artiste
qui coûtait en dedans je suis pas sûr et
ils étaient détruits à qu'après c'est
impossible de retourner en studio
lendemain c'est des interférences faut
faire très attention même avec les gens
avec qui on dit il faut faire attention
la mecque nos enfants trop faire
attention c'est des moments où on est en
train de se battre avec soin
vous êtes très proche de votre mère jane
birkin
vous avez déjà dit je n'ai pas voulu
lire son journal intime son son nouveau
livre
moi je les lui doyon il ya des passages
où elle montre cet artiste libre où
parfois les enfants allaient à gauche et
à droite
ce que jane birkin écrit dans son livre
ça m'a frappé ça c'est sûr et c'est que
c'est que la partie qu'elle a bien voulu
montrer donc effectivement oui c'était
très rock'n'roll
c'était très rock'n'roll et mais c'est
la beauté et la complication des
artistes et des enfants donc les enfants
d'artistes que les gens comprennent
souvent pas c'est que c'est qu'on a
aussi qu'on n'a pas eu de parents on a
eu des enfants merveilleux drôle fou
lumineux incroyable
qu'ils nous ont fait vivre des
expériences absolument insensé mais cdc
des grands enfants donc
donc c'est vrai que c'est des fois c'est
des fois c'est dur et des fois c'est
extrêmement rigolo mais c'est sûr que
même à l'époque déjà les les autres gens
vivaient pas comme ça c'était déjà une
vie assez exceptionnel à l'époque
aujourd'hui
oui ça serait sûrement plus du tout non
parce que ça prend ce déséquilibre là
pour un art by afin de grandeur c'était
une phrase de killswitch que j'aimais
beaucoup qui disait si les gens veulent
prendre de la coke pour pour être comme
moi c'est un peu triste
moi j'ai surtout passer 50 on a joué de
la guitare donc voilà c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas là c'est pas en touchant
la folie qu'on va se mettre à écrire des
chansons
par contre est-ce que pour être dans
wall a je pense qu'il ya mille exemples
des gens qui ont dévié extrêmement
scènes saida et ils ont besoin de ça
pour réussir à travailler le sensible
[Musique]
vous avez dit que vous avez voulu vous
mettre en danger avec votre troisième
album
pourquoi et comment contrairement à la
cuisine sais pas si on refait la même
chose à chaque fois que la chose devient
meilleur il faut un peu aller trouver
ddd des endroits qui nous dérange qui
nous réveille qui nous qui nous révèle à
nous mêmes aussi parce que on apprend
des choses sur soi des consommer en
danger donc là il y avait l'idée de ce
tir comment est-ce qu'on se remet au
travail
comment est ce qu on réapprend tout ils
habitent
lou doillon vous êtes une baisse de 5
mannequin actrice chanteuse et sur scène
votre corps prend son envol et quand
même vous êtes approprié ce corps pour
être ici à la sauce être soumis au
jugement s'est bizarrement ce qui
terrifie le plus l'être humain et en
même temps être adulé c'est le plus
grand fantasme de l'être humain donc
c'est une sorte de l'étrange mélange des
deux et je pense que ayant fait ses
métiers depuis que je suis petit et
aussi depuis que je suis enfant avoir
des gens qui me regardent qui me jugent
avant même que j'aie pu parler
effectivement ça fait que ça fait qu'on
tient debout alors je dirais pas que je
fais très à l'aise mais en tout cas je
tiens debout du doyon merci
[Musique]